[Music]  my husband and I are planning our family  Janet Jackson is officially a mom I'm  very happy the pop icon welcomed her  first child with husband Wisam al mana  et was first to break the news in May  that the 50 year old was expecting a  baby thank you to all the fans for your  love your undying love your loyalty  Janet's exciting announcement forced her  to postpone her unbreakable world tour I  have to rest up doctor's orders  but I have not forgotten about you  I will continue the tour as soon as I  possibly can the singer maintained a low  profile during her pregnancy she was  spotted strolling with her man in London  one thing's for sure though Janet is  going to be one fantastic mama my family  means everything